A vacation can be relaxing, exciting, and fun...
...unless you and your travel partner spend the entire time...
...arguing about where to go and what to do.
You will need: an agenda, a budget,...
...an ability to compromise, breaks and a sense of humor.
Optional: an overnight trip.
Step 1: Understand that different people like to experience traveling in different ways.
One person may prefer to have a meticulously detailed schedule,...
...while another may prefer to wing it.
Test the waters by going away for only one night on your first trip with a travel partner.
Step 2: Make an agenda, itemizing what each of you wants to see or do on the trip.
Be open to any situations that arise on the trip that may be more fun or interesting...
...than what is outlined in the itinerary.
Step 3: Set up a budget for the trip that clearly outlines...
...how much the trip is going to cost.
Specify every expense and determine how much each person is responsible for.
Step 4: Be willing to compromise.
Compromise means that sometimes both parties have to give up...
...a little of something they want to make each other happy.
Step 5: Take a break from each other.
If you have travel plans that conflict, or one of you wants to stay in the hotel,...
...split off and meet back together later.
Step 6: Work off each other's strengths and weaknesses.
If your partner is better at planning, and you are better at taking pictures,...
...then do what you are good at.
Step 7: Have a sense of humor.
It is often easier to get along...
...when you and your partner can share a laugh about your travel experiences.
Did you know?
According to the United Nations World Tourism Organization,...
...in 2008, international tourism generated 944 billion dollars.